in my research I was able to set the
statistics on so what are the key topics
for co-founder Phi there are seven
overall
um but beyond this uh you know objective
topics there are many more uh underlying
unconscious sometimes psychological
issue
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm really excited to talk to you you're
a startup and co-founder psychologist
working with with lots of really
interesting Founders I believe
interviewed hundreds of startup Founders
in the larger range of the hundreds and
so I'm really excited to dive in with
you as to you know your experience and
your expertise and what you've found to
be working and not working and you know
we we hear a lot about you know couples
therapists and psychologists and family
psychologists and now we're going to
talk about co-founder and psychology so
what is even the field that we're
talking about here
so this field is all about how
co-founder fight each other and build
strong relationship the class did to
enable the startup growth because 65
percent I don't know if you know this
data point 65 percent of startups who
fail are due to toxic or conflictual
co-founder relationship
um so I was you know very much
interested to dip in and understand much
more about when it comes from what they
fight about and if I can assist
to actually help the relationship to be
stronger and healthier so they to enable
the scale to help them to grow together
and build a wonderful business that they
wish
here where
a lot of the responders are splitting
and therefore the company is you know
you know is stopping services and and
that's uh it didn't turns out that it's
quite a big percentage of the cases
where companies fail right and so let's
talk a little bit about the why you know
what's happening there you know why are
there so many
issues around you know within the in the
communication between co-founders
yeah I just want to mention that it's
not
um new to me what you're saying that you
didn't know because this is a very much
unspoken
um topic you know
um most of the founder don't feel
comfortable or legit to talk about I
think that today I can hear more and
more people or see more and more
articles but when I started six years
ago my business
um you know like any founder
entrepreneur I went and do and did a
market research and I interviewed more
than 400 founder all around in different
stages from the business perspective
after I visited you know I went to so
many conferences and so many meetups Etc
but I didn't find much about this topic
so I said I will do the research myself
um and so I actually you know it's a
working process I am still interviewing
people but I have now body of knowledge
and I based my clinic based you know on
that and today I'm working with
couple Trio four five Founders that you
know started their business together
and they have their awareness and the
understanding that the relationship
their alignment their
um
um joint accountability is actually a
growth engine and without that
um you will see more and more splits and
Silo in the organization in the startup
you will
see more and more decision that are
being made in a
desynchronized way and its impact the
ability to grow so they have the mindset
and the
awareness that it's important some of
them come to me when they have a crisis
um like couple you know when they feel
that there are elephants in the room
when they feel that something is not
working well and some of them are with
me for four or five years because they
understand that they need to invest time
and effort and intention in maintaining
this trustworthy relationship because
you know walking in a startup is such a
chaotic and stressful environment and
like every couple that is going through
kite slices in their life they need
someone as a third party to help them to
navigate through this complexities
100 okay and so people come to you when
they see some red flags but obviously
there is the more ideal time to to do
this type of work you know for anything
from you know from the beginning just
always do the work because this is the
relationship you need to maintain it but
but more tangibly what are the red flags
that you are that you would consider as
red flags that would yield to a
co-founders saying okay we need to go
and and resolve this with the
professional who can help us
so mainly when I will help people you
know Founders say
we do not speak the same language it's
like we have broken communication
between us he or she doesn't understand
me and I don't feel like I understand
being understood this is one second they
will say I have so we have so many
fights and conflicts around how the
product should be what is our strategy
um how should we stay to go to market
should it be on this region or that
region so I will see
um conflict on the content of the
starter okay the the
um the actual business issues that they
are fighting on I will hear more about
I'm a co-founder I'm the CTO here Shield
the CEO but they are not my manager
so we are together in this we are equal
but suddenly the startup grow and I'm
not as equal as my partner
um I will heal fights on money
by around how we spend the money or
where we cut our spec you know expenses
during this period of this session you
will more and more fights on that topic
um
I will see cases when one of the founder
is going to the to a location to
establish a new site and the distance
relationship impact you know the feeling
how we close and aligned and we really
advise with each other like we were at
the beginning so this change is actually
required a an adjustment and they don't
know how to do this adjustment
um so these are types of issue that I
will hear and to be honest most of this
visible
clear objective reason
uh just on the surface because under the
surface there are more psychological and
personal uh needs that are not being
addressed so in my research I was able
to set the statistics also what are the
key topics for co-founder Phi there are
seven overall
um but beyond this uh you know objective
topics there are many more uh underlying
unconscious sometimes psychological
issues
okay so how you know and do these each
need to specialized treatment or do you
do you see some some things that
Founders can do to mitigate a lot of
this miscommunication that is taking
place I I hear it a lot and what the
what you are saying is that a lot of
cases you know you start off well and
then something changes whether it be an
environmental change a circumstantial
change a change in the you know just a
evolutionary change and that results in
some miscommunication or misalignment so
what what do we do with those situated
those moments and those inflection
points
um I think there are several things
Founders can do in advance
in order to avoid this and I can you
know list some of the things that by
increasing the self-awareness and
embedding at you know up front these
processes and routines between the
co-founder it can really help them
um to maintain their relationship and
sometimes when they need a support
so it is customized because they have
their personality they have their nature
they have their way sometimes even the
vertical that they are operating it will
impact
um but it is a customized process
um and it's always a combination between
the psychological driver that lead to
this conflicts or fights or broken
communication and the structured
elements like how we build a very clear
decision-making process let's agree on
the world's responsibility and what
happened when you disagree on something
so I will help them you know to tackle
or to clarify and to touch more the
spectral elements and the psychological
elements
100 completely and so if we're now I'd
love to sort of paint a picture of of
what sort of this interaction is with
you uh you know in the day-to-day so how
how frequently do you usually meet what
are the sort of mediums is it you know
pretty much like a regular psychology
session is there is there different
content than the traditional psychology
session
it's
um
it's a business psychology so we do meet
in a frequent structured consistent way
once a week or once of you know
bi-weekly because I believe that setting
this routine is part of
you know the the solution that they
decide then they have a shell time where
they talk about how we work together
listen most of the founder when they
choose the co-founder they match the
co-founder based on the professional
resume I'm a c I am a good in business
you're good in technology okay let's
match I have an idea let's go and do it
they really
will match their co-founder based on the
relationship resume it means
do you ask how your potential co-founder
are in relationship what is their
personal Dynamic how they communicate
how they address fights you know
question that needs to be part of the
matching process
but most of them do not address those
topics and then they start to work
together and statically they need to you
know
they are realizing new stuff on their
co-founder and to be honest they also
don't know themselves it's Fountain
because they are new to these process
most of them are new entrepreneur this
is you know the first time of building a
business in a very stressful and in
changing environment
and they need to to manage with each
other and they don't know each other
very well
so
um
I meet people
that sometimes they don't really know
the history they'll pass their
preferences their expectation how they
communicate what are their triggers and
in this session that we meet every week
or every two weeks it's their time to
reflect on the world together and
actually to Define you know how they
want to walk that they both or the three
of them or the four of them will be at
their best
because it's not very trivial from the
beginning also when we talk about
founder and grime most of the founder
agreements include items like you know
the equity legal what happened you know
which we run out of money Etc but people
do not include into the founder
agreement the psychological contract
items like
what do I need in order to flourish or
what happened when we disagree how we
manage that or what is my expectation uh
from this business do I want you know to
two years and then do an exit or do I
want to build an everlasting
organization it's two different
expectation and vision and so you need
to discuss those item as part of the
founder agreement right
so in those session they will talk about
what part of them they will talk about
the conflicts we will try to address
issues we will try to understand how
they perceive situation because you know
the reality is from the eye of the
people the person that is looking and
sometimes broken communication comes
from the fact that people give different
interpretation the situation and when
they decide to sit together and analyze
and reflect in retrospect it helps them
to manage better the future weeks so
this is what we are doing
yeah I mean the thing is it all comes
down to expectations and communication
around those expectations right
yes and
you know I don't know how you are when
you are in Conflict what is your
automatic reaction
think about yourself
you know sometimes the way we behave in
our startup with the co-founder is the
same with our significant other old
spouse
so what happened to you under
uncertainty or under stress how you
communicate with people so we are coming
from completely different history
different family and the first place
that we shape our personality and we
build our relational capacity is at home
with our sibling
um and the authority is mother and
father
and many times it's been projected when
we are working with our partners to the
startup
um so it's so trivial it's so you know
no man that fights and disagreements and
different way of looking at things and
different perspective we happen when we
are building a startup together and
because the startup is changing so much
regardless of the evolution you know
that today we have 10 people and
tomorrow we will be 50 people and now we
have two customers and and next week we
will have 50 customers so the noises
from the outside are also impacting our
relationship and our ability
um to be aligned
yeah no no completely
I think that the distinction that the
the relationship perhaps closely
resembles that of a significant other
and therefore you know we need to pay
close attention to our response
mechanisms you know Fife fight or flight
mechanisms different ways of
communication understanding the
background that we're coming from you
know it at the end it sounds like a lot
about giving respect to the situation
and giving respect to the complexity of
the situation of what it means to be a
co-founder that it's much Beyond you
know just professionally you know
working together but really building you
know really birthing something to the
world that requires you know you to act
sort of as parents Ian and if both of us
we were raised in a family of our past
history taught us to avoid conflicts
because conflicts are not good we need
to keep silence we need to keep the
harmony so imagine we have took off out
there that there are immediate tendency
or their automatic reaction would be to
avoid not to say anything to swallow
and after a year and two years they
build elephants between them because
they don't talk
and then something small will erase you
know bring a conflict
and
so this is you know two people in a
flight mechanism think about three
people with a fight mechanism
so how they manage how they understand
what happened to them and how they are
sensitive to the trigger to their
co-founded so this is not only about the
product and the strategy and the
marketing there is a lot about the
psychological aspect of each of them and
how they learn to work together in those
situations and we know that startups
bring so many stressful and you know
difficult situation
you know in many different relationships
and inform them I try to be very
intentional about about these
relationships and be very respectful of
how important and critical it is that
you know we have a clear communication
and and raise those good flags and I and
I go back to the original you know
statistics that you gave about the about
the how big of a problem this is you
know because you're saying that a lot of
the the majority of the reasons why
Starbucks fail is from Thunder
disagreements and so it sounds you know
a lot of Founders you know when they're
mapping out their widths you know I was
just in the investing meeting myself
today and the BC asked me you know
Michael what risk are you looking at for
your company and it didn't even occur to
me the risk of sound or disagreement as
a as an existential risk for a company
and personally I also so don't think
it's an existential risk for for our
company but I really but I but but now
that you're saying this I realize that
probably you know 99 of the founders
hearing that question won't think of
this as a potential risk for their
organization right because usually
the fight or the conflict or the
disagreement will be demonstrated in
disability to achieve product Market
feed or difficulty to
um
gain more and more customer or maintain
them and retain them okay because the
technology and the sale are not aligned
because the product and the tech are not
aligned and so at the end
what we will see uh
um complexity in the business
and slow down in the way of the startup
to grow and to scale and finally to
raise money
this is 100
and I really I really want to thank you
for for this time and your energy and
the great work and obviously the huge
positive impact you're having on many
Founders and co-founders thank you for
for coming on and sharing the stand with
me I really appreciate it thank you
thank you so much
thank you